bro yo oh when you guys know you have to
do this you're like
they love it they love to watch the
puppies I'm Penn Badgley and we're all
here with BuzzFeed to play with some
puppies you virtually me actual I love
dogs
[Music]
hey guy do they have names can I call
them they don't have names today
Hercules hi hi there's more than two
come
you really think they're interested in
me they want to hoop and pee and play
[Music]
it was like this was like herding
puppies come I mean I was surrounded by
supporting casts of British people who
all just constantly refer to as puppies
now it was nice I'm always real isolated
as Joe I could use puppies when I'm
playing Joe I could really use puppies
and lions frankly McGill
honestly when I got coveted I had 10
days off and I listened to Kendrick's
record it was perfect timing the day
that I got covered Kendrick Trekker
dropped I laid in bed listened to
Kendrick and I watched uh Charlotte
Ritchie's show show which is my co-star
in this season her show ghosts go watch
that and Star Trek I became a Trekkie
a bunch one I got close on was a
Breaking Bad it was between me and her
and Paul we tested and actually that was
the best television script I'd read at
that point that was the one that got
away
spoiler alert just beware which plotline
was the most shocking
all right you just want common safety
here's to me what was what was most
shocking about the reveal with love yeah
she's a killer right but then that Joe
hates her for it like it makes so much
sense
hi it was really depressing
I thought they were going to be like
Bonnie and Clyde and then who wants to
kill her immediately go figure
[Music]
that's not a room I want to be in Joe
wouldn't speak and Dan wouldn't shut up
I wonder if Joe would have read Dan's
book he probably would want to kill Dan
and Dan deserves it come here
[Music]
oh you all want this don't you you all
want this you all want to know that love
was a killer again sorry spoiler alert
if you haven't seen it
[Music]
cardi B was a trip we've still never met
to this point
Conan O'Brien oh but he's not a fan of
you he's a fan of Gossip Girl that was a
surprise a very pleasant surprise
[Music]
you know what I do every season I take
sweatpants honestly like they give me
sweatpants at some point that I have to
wear and at the end of the season I take
them and like boxers it makes me sound
cheap I guess but it's easy
come on we got to give them content they
want content come here come here
all right so I got to tell you my for
you page is still not calibrated to me
I've not been on long enough and
actually I when I swipe I'm horrified
I'm just like what is this hellscape I
do not want to be a part of this but
then but then I am I'm a major part of
it
we want car to be on the show I'm just
gonna go out and say that
um
this guy keeps starting you know
every time somebody asks me who my top
top top would be is The Impossible the
ungettable Kendrick I mean just because
I think such a Storyteller already it's
not like we need to hear from him about
his middle school days but I would be so
interested and he would never come on
maybe maybe we could get him
[Applause]
chopping up Malcolm's body made me more
nauseous than any of the others we had
to shoot a lot of inserts for that one
it's so hard to focus I want to make
sure that you're enjoying yourself
[Music]
Leighton trying to get her husband on my
show
[Music]
I mean I can't say never because I just
don't know you know it would have to be
super compelling I think no I'm going on
records saying I think
no I do like a non-fiction sort of
journalistic kind of vibe like a like
Spotlight it was a brilliant film you
know it's an ensemble you don't you
don't even need to have a romantic
relationship in that I I I I love that
you know
you go
so literally I shot for eight days in
Ojai it was the whole thing was a
pleasant memory it was like it was like
in the beautiful desert Malcolm McDowell
called me like lovingly because I was
all in blue and I think one time I ran
through the poster and I ran into him
and then he just sort of laughed it goes
you look like I think I probably did you
know
I do remember like the first season of
Gossip Girl there was like there was
like a 12 year old who was so precocious
it was like a gaggle of girls who went
to those schools so she was like a real
life Gossip Girl and I'm pretty sure it
was me Blake maybe Leighton but this
girl was like trying to invite us up to
her home and so needing it my first
question when she said that I was like
where do you live and Blake was like
don't ask her where she lives and I was
like no no no no no no I'm not going to
go I was in disbelief
[Music]
I mean look we designed him to be
thirsty he's meant to be thirst inducing
he's like a desert like a raging hot
desert this makes you so thirsty
I mean they all go so quick I have it's
like a new cast every season maybe Benji
from season one Lou Taylor Pucci did a
phenomenal job so come here Barbie hi
[Music]
that the neighbor in season three teased
at the end of season two was Joe's mom
definitely was never going to be the
case
come on
directing was a lovely treat I really
took to it I'm going to direct more
probably not of my own show it's so hard
to to do both at once when you have no
time for playback it was like directing
with my eyes closed those two fight
[Music]
there is a phenomenal Italian restaurant
I've not been to in years I'm pretty
sure it's called scalinatella it's on
63rd Street they never tell you how much
anything is every time you get the bill
it's different it's really high and it's
like what it was the first time I ever
had um truffle and it is phenomenal
he would he would hate it
he'd be hurt
no you're just you're not adopted yet
you know how to do that thank you
BuzzFeed for letting me play with your
puppies season four part one you Netflix
watch it when you have the time all of
these puppies are adoptable at rescue
City
oh well I need to shave I know bye
[Music]